Obviously, the data carries a lot of information.
I'll now teach you how to visualize the data,
using a simple trick called a scatter plot.
For that, I want you to take a piece of paper and a pen or a pencil
and arrange the data in a graph where the x axis is the size, and the y axis is the price.
In a scatter plot, each data item becomes a dot.
If we graph different sizes horizontally and prices vertically,
the very first data item can be graphed as follows.
You draw a line that's vertical at size 1400.
Every house on this dotted like is of the same size--1400.
You draw a horizontal line at the price of $98,000, just below $100,000.
Where these two lines meet you have your very first data point.
This dot corresponds to the very first house in your list of data.
Let's do the same for the second house.